look it's no surprise that um
african-american males are still
overwhelmingly cast
as not the great guys it's it's just a
fact of life
um you know
i think in some cases it's shifted a
little
and there's probably certainly more
roles available today
as positive roles than it was say 20
years ago um
but it's got a long way to go right i
mean a long
long way to go and uh i don't i'm not
really sure what it's gonna
what it's gonna take like you know i
just saw that
denzel washington wants to play james
bond and
that'd be great i don't think it's ever
gonna happen
i don't think it's gonna happen because
it's you just he's
black guys are not that guy you know
we're not that
but you know you could be the doctor you
could be the
pilot you could be but you know and now
you could be the president
right on occasion i mean morgan freeman
played the president uh
once or twice but um there's just not
enough positive roles that are
reflective of the positive
of some of the positive people that are
in the society at large you know it's
still
very like it's easy to be the robber or
the drug dealer or the
you know janitor you know i just had a
i had a job and i was originally hired
to play like
the lead lawyer but then when i went and
showed up they actually were like yeah
well you know
he actually they changed the last minute
he's the more
lawyerly type well yeah he's the more
loyally tight because he's the white guy
and he probably looks like you know he
could be of like maybe a jewish
background so
more stereotypical the stereotype worked
for him
didn't necessarily work for me right but
that
that happens and it's unfortunate well
it used to be a lot of
the african-american ghetto girl but i
feel like they've
done such a good job of branching out of
that and i'm
so grateful for that because i'm so not
the ghetto girl
so i'm really happy about that because
now we have making good
she does the mean girl she did deception
last year and she was playing the
detective
and that was just great we have
kerry washington doing scandal fantastic
even on the following we have
african-american girl that's
around my age that's um playing joe
carroll's like step-daughter-ish
type of thing and she's african-american
playing against kevin bacon
like that's awesome and i think that the
industry is definitely kind of
starting to open up doors for us and i
really appreciate it because i'm here
and i'm ready
it always depends on where you're
looking i mean i feel like
there have been some things that have
been really really great for
african-american males like you have
things like
you know 12 years of slave that just
came out with some really really you
know um
she without a force you know amazing
actor and then you have
a lot of sitcoms now that having like
like black-ish
or you know like thinking back a little
like the game and like
these actors are it's almost like it's a
very um
similar niche of a type um for actors i
mean i feel like
i think it's getting better it's not so
much like the whole urban thing you know
it's like it's okay for um a black guy
to be articulate when he speaks
it's okay for him to be like wealthy in
a show you know it's not so much like
let's look at this guy in a gang
so i mean i think it's actually getting
a lot better honestly i think being an
asian is really hard
really hard in the industry like to
um and acting wise even in singing
it's really hard to get in to show or
show business in any kind of business
like acting
or singing or even dancing just because
for example usually
asians like if you have um i'm filipino
so if you
i have tan skin color so i wouldn't be
playing filipino
you know i mean i'd be playing either
mexican or american indian i mean i've
never seen or i have not seen any
shows like tv shows that had like
straight on a filipino character the
only one that
i know that i um there is an asian
person or a filipino person playing a
filipino character
is um the teenage the secret life of the
teen of a teenage
of american teenager when she's it's
basically a story about how she's
pregnant how she gets pregnant at a
young age but one of the characters
there
is filipino annie plays a filipino
character so that's the only time that
i saw that someone that's really
filipino is playing a filipino character
but
anything else it's usually like filipino
playing a mexican like another example
is um
vanessa and hudgins she's half filipino
or um
rob schneider he's a filipino also he's
half filipino half jewish so
i think people who are half filipino
have a better inn
than being like filipino-american like
me i don't
i don't know why but it's just um from
what i've observed
it's way easier when you're half because
i think when you're half
you don't look quite filipino first
gender
being female sexual everything it's like
i thought the girl is
sexual she's a tomboy she's like a
little nerdy type of girl
you know that's the categories that were
being but more so
sexy everything's just sexy and uh
as a black female is more so okay well
either you're like once again either
you're playing this
this you know not so educated
or you're the bougie black girl you know
the one that
the one token black girl is what i like
to call it and i'm used to that because
i went to a private school in my life in
boarding school i was the one token
african girl so for me
like oh it's one token black girl okay
so that's where you are or you're just
you're just the the hard-ass girl like
the hard-ass black girl
don't mess with her you know she can be
ghetto but she can't be she can also be
proper
but don't mess with her so
i'm it's just i want to see more comedic
black women out there you know that's
what i really want to see
if it's not a slave in the amistad you
know once again it's
a crooked cop if i do get the rankings
of actually getting the opportunity to
play officer i'm
i'm always technically going to be the
bad guy or portrayed to be the bad guy
at least for the character
not necessarily saying the production is
making me trey carswell a bad guy
to the world because you know once again
we have fans people love us as actors
but it does sucks when you know you have
that traditional
outlook as far as like the
african-american male being an actor
like i said it's always plugged back
into being that villain
and like i said it's coming which sucks
because it's also you know that's what
you get in media
and that these are the things that you
know change our thoughts and
that controls our minds and how we think
and view things in life and once again
if you always have that same
vision or you know that same image of an
african-american male like oh he's a bad
guy
you're going to probably just also look
at that person too in life
so i'm not comfortable with it you know
the the traditional
betrayal of a african-american male
being some type of
crook